bonjour nous sommes le 7 novembre 2007
je suis avec mon camarade de cordée
depuis plus de 20 ans lionel et nous
quittons le camp de base un camp de base
dans l'himalaya au népal dans le dos le
pot c'est la région où ils malaga en
france d'un chef a été tourné pour ceux
qui connaîtraient ce film film d'eric
valli la région est magnifique on vient
de faire un gros set milk est un sommet
satellite du doubs laguérie on quitte le
camp de base le jour et pas levé il est
très tôt le matin tout va bien on à
l'expédition s'est bien passé et on part
en un peu en arrière de tout le monde et
on suit le médecin qui est un petit peu
devant nous et voilà tout va bien la vie
est belle on est en train de profiter
des derniers instants en très haute
altitude on est à 5005 encore et on
s'apprête à descendre pour rejoindre la
vallée
trois jours plus tôt trois jours plus
tôt nous étions dans ce camp sous quand
roy qui était le dernier camp avant
d'atteindre le sommet si les camps con
con mais qu'on de façon à jalonner le
trajet entre un camp de base dans
l'himalaya et le sommet qui soit sur les
hauteurs de sept ou huit mille et le
lendemain le 5 novembre nous étions au
sommet un sommet sans histoire sans
aucun problème on est et on est arrivés
tôt au sommet vers 10h30 un peu près
groupe et pour tout le monde n'est pas
monté en haut parce que les gens étaient
d'une forme inégale il y avait des gens
qui ont peint évidemment pas réussi à
tout faire mais globalement c'était un
succès collectif
est arrivé tôt il faisait beau on a pu
rester fait exceptionnel un peu près une
heure au sommet ce qui est assez rare
pas trop de vent voilà mon camarade de
grimpe lionel voilà un autre camarade
important parce angle qui avait déjà
fait le sommet c'est pour ça qu'il est
venu avec nous il joue un rôle
particulier on a on l'a c'est quelqu'un
avec qui on entretient une relation
depuis pas mal d'années au népal et on
est rentré ensuite en deux jours au camp
base en des équipes en or descendant en
enlevant les camps et dont comparses ce
7 novembre
on suit le médecin et ce médecin devant
nous comment ça a marché d'une façon un
peu bizarre il commence à évoluer de
façon un peu déséquilibré comme s'ils
perdaient comme si son oreille interne
avait été impacté et on s'approche de
lui on le rejoint et puis on voit qu'il
est complètement en train de partir en
vrille
on le fait ça soir et on voit qu'il est
en train de sombrer très très vite on
interprète ça comme un oedème cérébral
qui est à une pathologie assez répandu
quand on est très haut en montagne
l'oedème pulmonaire l'oedème cérébral
sont des pathologies qui surviennent du
fait de la défaite du différentiel de
pression et donc on commence à prendre
soin de lui moi je cours recherchez les
autres qui sont partis devant pour
récupérer un peu de pharmacie collective
on le met sous cortisone aspirine
vasodilatateur ce qu'on a l'habitude de
faire dans ces cas là et il commence à
partir c'est à dire qu'ils commencent
vraiment à s'enfoncer et on n'arrive pas
à le récupérer
donc on installe au mieux en plus le
temps est pourri alors c'est pas ça va
on est plus bas ça va mais le temps est
quand même pourri et là on réussit à
réunir à peu près tout le monde sachant
qu'il ya des gens qui sont partis un peu
de vent on était un peu plus clairsemés
c'était le départ les yaks son parti
devant un tout gros matos on n'a pas de
corps on n'est pas vraiment bien équipé
et là on est confronté à une première
décision qui est de savoir ce qu'on va
faire
parce qu'en fait le chemin qui nous
emmène de ce camp de base
vers la vallée et l'on est bourré
d'arette il est compliqué c'est plus la
théorie de grande taille mais c'est
encore sérieux et en fait la question
qui se pose collectivement c'est de
savoir si on peut le descendre ou pas
quoi ou est ce qu'il faut le laisser
vous imaginez la discussion alors on se
réunit et tout le monde et pas gaillard
il ya des gens qui sont physiquement en
crever on est deux jours après le sommet
et ça faisait plusieurs semaines qu'on
était sur la montagne
en même temps il ya des gens qui sont
physiquement costaud encore mais qui
sont émotionnellement très atteint par
ce qui se passe il ya des gens qui
pleurent concrètement ce jour là parce
hang que vous avez vu
enrique vous n'avez pas vu qu est un
anglais est en forme et moi ça va aussi
et en fait on prend une demi décision en
fait on prend la décision de se dire on
sait pas si on va y arriver il ya ces
énormes tout ce qui est à faire
le toubib est dans les 81 kg il est
complètement il est commun comme une
poupée si vous voulez on sait pas si ça
va servir à quelque chose on sait qu'on
sait en revanche que si on descend et
assez vite faut pas descendre vite mais
on sait quand on gagne en en diminuant
la pression on lui donne une chance et
on décide de faire un peu de faire une
méthode un peu testan leur envie on sait
pas si on va y arriver mais on va faire
100 m on va déjà faire 100 m on fait le
point
et puis on fait 100 m et puis en fait
100 m qui se trouve qu'il ya un
différentiel de taille entre angie et
moi
henrie plus grand et le tout le parcours
est en arrêt très incliné et on a un
petit morceau de corps donc pas sans que
se met derrière attaché à la taille not
not toubib et
et on commence comme ça qui ont fait 100
m puis on refait sans même qu'ils ont
refait 100 m c'est un enfer
c'est un enfer total et ça va durer de 5
6 heures du matin jusqu'à minuit et on
va y arriver
in fine et on va y arriver c'est qu'on
va réussir à le descendre mais il ya
vraiment des moments où vous vous
demandez dans ces cas là je suis marié
j'ai deux enfants je les avais déjà à
l'époque et il ya des moments où vous
dites non c'est pas possible je vais pas
continuer quoi je vais je risque
vraiment de deux dit pas c'est que je
connais daniel je connais ce toubib on
le connaît déjà d'exp mai mais bon voilà
mais on rit ça et on continue et on
continue et puis on a réussi comme ça
chemin faisant à descendre jusque dans
le fond de la vallée rouge et pas
beaucoup de photos parce que ce n'était
pas vraiment le moment mais mais mais
voilà c'était c'était compliqué on a
réussi progressivement à rejoindre 3005
est un petit village on savait qu'on
pourrait trouver une mule
là on s'est posé dans une auberge on l'a
réveillé plusieurs fois durant la nuit
pour pas qu'ils sombrent dans un commun
encore un peu plus profond
et puis le lendemain on l'a mis sur une
sur une mule et on l'a et puis on est
parti après pour un long périple
ça c'est trois jours après 100
kilomètres plus loin parce qu'il a fallu
tout tour serré donc vraiment aller à
fond et mais on l'a sauvé on a sauvé il
a gardé des séquelles il ya qu'il a
perdu beaucoup de mémoire il a tout le
côté gauche qui restaient paralysés mais
on a réussi à leurs descendants
c'était une expérience très très dur
franchement vous voyez même encore
aujourd'hui ça fait huit ans j'ai du mal
à en parler de façon normale parce que
je me suis demandé si je devais c'est
jusqu'au bout de cette expérience
mais on l'a fait pour la sauver est ce
qu'il faut retenir de cette histoire si
on prend un peu de recul et on se prend
un peu le contrôle de nos émotions
le premier c'est que bon ça c'est une
autre montagne que j'ai fait il ya il ya
cinq ans mais ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que le premier point c'est que ce
toubib il avait triché il avait triché
il était responsable de la pharmacie
collective est en fait il sait il a
dépassé ses limites
il a dépassé ses limites il n'a pas
voulu d écouter par orgueil il sait sur
medicare on pouvait pas contrôler il
était sur la pharmacie collective donc
il a triché la tricherie avec lui et il
a triché avec nous et on ne peut pas
tricher
quand on engage la responsabilité des
autres cette façon là donc ça c'est un
premier message
le deuxième message c'est que tout le
monde n'était pas au top ce jour là mais
c'était normal en était après une
ascension qui est quand même dur hein
mais la solidarité qu'on avait entre
nous était très forte et ça nous a
vraiment sauvé on a terminé dans les
état pitoyable les uns et les autres
mais on a réussi parce qu on s'est
entraidés donc on a fait preuve de
solidarité
et puis le dernier message qu'il faut
retenir c'est que ça a généré
j'ai des souvenirs en fait c'est mon
plus beau souvenir de montagne et c'est
en même temps de plus terrible mais mais
ça ça tisser des liens vraiment
fraternelle
entre nous et voilà et je vais je vais
terminer là dessus sur l'honnêteté sur
la solidarité et sur la trt a terni t
merci